.
* "Tagesschau"-Signet *
Nicht nur das Coronavirus geht
weiter um, auch die Angst davor.
Im Moment
ist das Virus schon überall.
Grosse Veranstaltungen
sollen abgesagt werden.
Wir sind alle gefordert,
jeder und jede einzelne.
(Daniel Koch) Es ist die Krankheit,
die eigentlich den Takt vorgibt.
Der Blick auf die Europakarte
zeigt kaum ein Land,
das noch keinen Corona-Fall meldet.
Vor drei Wochen
habe ich mit den Dreharbeiten
für diesen Film begonnen.
Wir wollten dokumentieren,
wie sich das Virus
auch auf unseren ganz persönlichen
Lebensbereich auswirkt.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
hätte ich mir nicht träumen lassen,
dass Corona unseren Alltag
in kürzester Zeit wegfegt.
Die Menschen haben die Angst:
"Ich sterbe bald."
Wir müssen uns
auf eine Situation einstellen,
die sehr anders ist:
etwas für die Geschichtsbücher.
Wenn nur noch drei Personen kommen,
ist das für meine Existenz
ziemlich schwierig.
(Alle) Co-ro-na!
- Fuck you.
14 Personen ...
Ich wurde überrollt von den
Geschehnissen, so wie das ganze Land.
Eine Chronik der Eskalation.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Es ist der 5. März.
In der ganzen Schweiz werden
Grossveranstaltungen abgesagt.
Das Konzert von Patent Ochsner
in Bern darf noch stattfinden.
Ich mache mich auf den Weg,
um zu schauen,
ob sich die Leute
ins Bierhübeli wagen.
Und ich stelle fest:
Noch ist die Stimmung unbeschwert.
Abstand halten in Schlangen, bitte.
- Ja, genau.
Abstand halten in Schlangen.
- Das ist wahr. 2 m oder wie viel?
1,5 m.
Zu unbeschwert, aus heutiger Sicht.
Die ersten Warnungen sind noch nicht
beim Publikum angekommen.
Es gilt ab sofort die Bestimmung:
Nur noch 1'000 Personen
dürfen ins Lokal.
Der Veranstalter steht täglich
in Kontakt mit den Behörden.
Ihm ist klar, dass es eng wird.
Die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
sind noch nicht abschätzbar.
Wir haben natürlich
auch Kundenanlässe.
Die meisten davon wurden verschoben
oder abgesagt.
Das wird ein riesiges Defizit
verursachen.
Es ist sehr schwierig abzuschätzen.
Wir haben eine soziale Verantwortung
unseren Mitarbeitern gegenüber.
Jetzt haben wir
Kurzarbeit beantragt.
Here we go!
* Entspannte Musik *
Noch dominiert die Festlaune.
Heute wirken diese Bilder
wie aus einer anderen, fernen Zeit.
Verkauft wurden 950 Tickets.
Nur 200 Personen sind nicht gekommen.
* Jubel, Applaus, Pfiffe *
Vielen Dank. Ich sage heute Abend
das einzige Mal dieses Wort:
(Alle) Co-ro-na!
- Fuck you.
* Lachen, Jubel, Applaus *
Jetzt geht das Leben los.
Der Song heisst ...
Die Realität ist umgekehrt.
Eine Woche
wird Patent Ochsner noch spielen.
Dann kommt das Verbot.
Das Bierhübeli muss wie
unzählige andere Lokale schliessen.
* Fröhliche Musik, Klatschen *
Das Coronavirus
verbreitet sich schnell:
Nach einer Woche sind bereits 100
Menschen in der Schweiz infiziert.
Gestorben ist heute eine
74-jährige Frau im Kanton Waadt.
Die Fallzahlen der Corona-
Infizierten in der Schweiz
haben sich seit gestern verdoppelt:
210 Fälle hat das Bundesamt für
Gesundheit mittlerweile registriert.
Ab sofort
gelten neue Verhaltensregeln.
(Alain Berset)
C'est le social distancing.
Auf den Strassen
merkt man kaum etwas davon.
Sind wir alle zu leichtsinnig?
Ich bin unsicher.
Die journalistische Distanz
fällt mir zunehmend schwerer.
Bereits sind Desinfektionsmittel
überall ausverkauft.
Das gibt mir zu denken.
Mein Nachbar ist Arzt.
Ich habe ihn gebeten,
mir ein Sterillium
aus seiner Praxis mitzubringen.
Hallo! Hoi, Tobi.
- Ah, Andrea! Hoi.
Oh, toll, super, Sterillium!
- Schau mal. Genau.
Wunderbar. Einfach einreiben?
- Ja. Hast du keine Hautprobleme?
Es trocknet etwas aus. Ich kann ja
eincremen.- Kein Problem.
Wie läuft es in der Praxis?
- Wir merken es schon sehr.
Wir haben viele Anrufe,
die Leute rufen an.
Das sollen sie auch,
nicht einfach in die Praxis kommen.
Wir spüren es.
Es ist eine intensive Zeit momentan.
Grosse Verunsicherung?
Ja, ich glaube, wir alle wissen
nicht zu 100 %, was uns erwartet.
Wir versuchen, uns an die Guidelines
des Bundes zu halten.
Die sind schon gut.
- Okay.
Du bist ja auch in den Altersheimen,
gell?- Mhm.
Ich habe viele ältere Patienten.
- Und?
Sie nehmen es noch relativ
entspannt, muss ich sagen.
Sehr realistisch und entspannt.
Eher bei uns Jüngeren kann man
einen erhöhten Grundpuls spüren.
Vielen Dank.
- Sehr gern geschehen. Bleib gesund.
Ja, ich gebe mir Mühe.
Sonst komme ich zu dir.
Selbstverständlich, jederzeit.
- Tschüss!- Tschüss!
Gefährdete Menschen
sollen unnötige Kontakte vermeiden,
in Stosszeiten keinen ÖV benutzen.
Die Krankheit COVID-19
bedroht ältere Menschen.
Und wer per ÖV pendelt,
der soll Stosszeiten meiden.
9. März.
Dieser Zug ist sonst immer voll.
Langsam wird eine Veränderung
im öffentlichen Leben sichtbar.
Übertrieben oder sinnvoll?
Ich bin unterwegs
zu einem Interviewtermin in Genf,
um vom Wissenschaftler
Antworten zu bekommen.
Eine Antwort
bekomme ich schon im Taxi.
Am Radio ist nur noch Coronavirus,
Coronavirus, Coronavirus.
Alle haben Panik. Alle haben Angst.
Sie bleiben zu Hause,
sie gehen nicht mehr aus,
es ist fast das Ende der Welt.
Die Wissenschaftler
sollen sich an die Arbeit machen
und ein Medikament entwickeln.
Die Christen sollen beten,
dass die Krankheit aufhört.
Alle müssen etwas machen.
Am Biotech-Campus in Genf.
Epidemiologe Marcel Salathé
hat schon früh drastische Massnahmen
und flächendeckende Tests
zur Eindämmung von Corona gefordert.
Manche Stimmen
warfen ihm da Schwarzmalerei vor.
Diese Stimmen
sind inzwischen verstummt.
Wir sind leider laufend mit
Schreckensszenarien konfrontiert.
COVID ist einfach aussergewöhnlich,
weil es auch uns trifft.
Das ist etwas, was die Leute
in der Schweiz etwas aufschreckt.
Wir sind nicht
tagtäglich davon betroffen,
dass uns ein Moskito stechen könnte
und wir an Malaria sterben könnten.
Mit COVID sind wir plötzlich in
der Situation: Ah, es ist auch hier.
Das löst sicher viel Sorge aus.
Was heisst es für Sie persönlich?
Sie sind einerseits Wissenschaftler,
andererseits auch Mensch,
der betroffen ist.
Ich glaube, jeder,
der diese Krise miterlebt -
und das wird jeder tun -,
geht früher oder später durch den
Moment, im dem er realisiert: Shit!
Das passiert jetzt.
- Was heisst "Shit"? Ich habe Corona?
Im Stil von:
Es geht nicht mehr einfach weg.
Es ist ein Szenario, das man sich
über Jahrzehnte überlegt hat,
mit einer Pandemie eines Virus,
das sich verbreitet,
gegen das es kein Gegenmittel gibt.
Wir sind jetzt drin.
2020 ist jetzt dieses Jahr.
Ich glaube,
in dem Moment ist es unangenehm.
Für mich war das
vor etwa drei Wochen.
Seither kann ich dem Ganzen
relativ sachlich gegenüberstehen.
Okay, es geht nicht mehr darum,
zu hoffen, dass es verschwindet.
Sondern darum, sich zu überlegen:
Was sind die besten Massnahmen?
Wie kann man
das Schlimmste abfedern?
Worauf muss ich mich gefasst machen?
Die gesundheitliche Situation
ist sehr ernst.
Das ist es auch,
was wir Wissenschaftler
seit Wochen
zu kommunizieren versuchen.
Aber es ist kein Hollywood-Szenario,
wir müssen uns nicht
im Keller einbunkern.
Die Situation ist zwar ernst,
aber doch temporär.
Nächstes Jahr wird niemand mehr mit
solchen Bildern konfrontiert sein.
Es liegt jetzt wirklich an uns,
diese Sache bestmöglich zu managen.
Der Wissenschaftler berechnet
den Verlauf von Pandemien voraus.
Und ich begreife immer deutlicher,
dass dieses winzige Virus
auch meine eigene Realität
schon bald komplett verändern könnte.
Italien ist seit heute Morgen
ein Land im Ausnahmezustand.
Per Dekret dürfen nur noch Apotheken
und Lebensmittelläden öffnen.
Das Spitalpersonal arbeitet
bis zur totalen Erschöpfung.
Bilder aus den Spitälern
der Lombardei in Norditalien
sind alarmierend.
China war weit weg, Italien nicht.
Als Journalistin
bin ich permanent online.
Haben wir bald schon
Zustände wie in Italien?
10. März.
Ich besuche meinen Nachbarn
in seiner Hausarztpraxis.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich habe mit Tobi zum Dreh abgemacht.
Ja, ich bringe dich nach hinten.
- Super.
Was habt ihr erlebt?
- Täglich viele Anrufe.
Alle verunsichert,
das kann man sagen.
Und wie geht's dir dabei?
Ich fühle mich
irgendwie eingeschränkt.
Ich fühle mich auch
in der Freiheit eingeschränkt, klar.
Es ist schon beängstigend,
finde ich.
Es bringt Unruhe,
man denkt viel darüber nach:
Wie ist es mit dem Kind,
den Grosseltern und so?
Vielen Dank.
Ich rede jetzt noch mit Tobi.
Bloss nicht die Hand geben.
- Ja, genau!
Gut. Bis später. Tschüss.
- Ciao.
Hello!
- Hoi, Andrea.
Super, dass wir kommen dürfen.
- Gern geschehen.
Was ist bei euch so los?
Yvonne sagte, für sie sei es krass.
Was triffst du bei den Patientinnen
und Patienten an?
Momentan sind wir in einer Zeit,
in der jeder Husten,
jeder Schnupfen, jedes Halsweh
eine gewisse Verunsicherung auslöst.
Die Menschen haben die Angst:
"Ich sterbe bald."
Das ist das Hauptproblem.
Die Leute haben das Gefühl,
sie könnten daran sterben.
Ich bin stark daran, uns Gesunde
zu beruhigen und zu sagen:
"Du wirst daran nicht sterben."
Unsere Hauptaufgabe ist,
das Virus nicht
an die Risikopopulation
zu übertragen.
Wenn du das einhalten kannst
durch dein Verhalten,
Social Distancing, all das,
ist etwas ganz Wichtiges erfüllt.
Okay. Ich bin Ende 50,
schon fast in der Risikogruppe.
Nein, du bist noch nicht
in der Risikogruppe.
Sicher nicht?
- Nein, wirklich nicht.
Ich kenne dich.
Du bist erst an der Grenze und
sonst sehr leistungsfähig, gesund.
Du hast keine chronische Herz-
erkrankung, du bist eigentlich fit.
Er zeigt mir die improvisierte
Isolationsstation für Verdachtsfälle.
Seit heute dürfen
alle Ärzte und Ärztinnen testen.
Wir haben eine kleine Loggia.
Natürlich würde immer nur einer
aufs Mal hier Platz nehmen.
Es geht darum,
dass die MPA den Arzt rufen kann,
damit der Arzt wenn nötig
den Abstrich machen kann.
Machst du den im Mund?
Quer durch die Nase
und einmal im Mund.
Dann bespricht man mit dem Patienten
die nächsten Schritte.
Das Resultat des Abstrichs
hätten wir innert zwei Tagen.
Dann kann ich dem Patienten sagen,
ob es positiv oder negativ ist.
Und er wartet zu Hause?
Ja, wenn es der Gesundheitszustand
zulässt, soll er dort bleiben.
Schon kurz nach meinem Besuch
trifft die Corona-Welle auch
in der Praxis von Tobias Herold ein.
Andrea, hier ist noch mal Tobi.
Ich melde mich aus unserer Loggia.
Mittlerweile hat sich die Situation
etwas verändert.
Wir haben aktuell
bereits 20 Abstriche durchgeführt.
Glücklicherweise ist erst
einer davon positiv ausgefallen.
Der Patientin geht es
auf telefonische Nachfrage hin
eigentlich sehr gut.
Was kommt noch auf uns zu?
Ein Notstand?
Ich beginne,
meinen veränderten Alltag
auch mit meinem Handy
zu dokumentieren.
Der Verlust der Normalität
ist anstrengend.
Ausgleich hole ich seit Jahren
in meiner Yogagruppe.
Im Schnitt sind wir
zwölf Schülerinnen und Schüler.
Aber heute ist fast niemand da.
Versucht, den Atem
schön fliessen zu lassen.
Wir machen drei tiefe Atemzüge.
Ich kann nur schwer abschalten.
Corona ist überall.
Die Art und Weise
unseres Zusammenlebens
ist weltweit infrage gestellt.
Das haben wir alle noch nie erlebt.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Komm langsam nach vorne.
Solche Nähe -
heute schon völlig undenkbar.
Die Füsse flexen,
als müsstest du etwas wegstossen.
Und die Knie langsam
in Richtung Brustkorb ziehen.
Corina?
- Ja?
Kommen jetzt eigentlich immer
so wenige wie heute?
Ja, in jeder Stunde
immer etwas weniger.
Ich habe vor der Stunde
auch SMS von Schülern bekommen,
die sagten, sie kämen nicht mehr,
sie hätten Angst.
Wenn plötzlich immer
nur noch drei Personen kommen,
ist das für meine Existenz
ziemlich schwierig.
Wie lange hältst du durch,
wenn jetzt ...
Wenn jetzt noch die Quarantäne kommt,
kommt gar niemand mehr.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Nicht lange.
Wenn plötzlich
keine Schüler mehr kommen,
sicher einen Monat,
dann wird es schwierig.
Denn ich habe laufende Kosten.
Viele Leute
haben jetzt ziemlich Angst.
Es ist nicht Angst
vor einer Ansteckung,
sondern die Angst vor der Angst.
Man spürt es einfach in der Luft.
Merkst du es auch sonst?
Ich merke einfach, dass ...
... dass jeder so ein bisschen mehr
mit sich selbst beschäftigt ist
und sich selbst der Nächste ist.
Man versucht,
den eigenen Nutzen herauszuholen.
Hast du das Gefühl?
- Ja, diese Energie ist da.
Sie ist ein wenig aggressiv.
Ja, das finde ich.
Mal schauen. Vielleicht
ist es ja am Montag besser.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ach, schau her.
Du bist auch hier.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Das ist Andrea.
Darf ich dir ...
Machen wir es so?
Ich finde den Fusskick cool.
- Ach so, okay.
Du holst Corina ab.
- Ja, wir haben um 19 Uhr abgemacht.
Wir haben gerade über das Problem
geredet, dass so wenig Leute kommen.
Du bist doch auch
in der Unterhaltungsbranche.
Live-Kommunikation.
- Merkst du es auch?
Live-Kommunikation!
Mit deinen Licht-Geschichten.
Merkst du es auch?
Wie schlägt es sich bei euch nieder?
Wir haben drei, vier
grössere Projekte, Veranstaltungen
im ersten Quartal,
Generalversammlungen, Konzerte,
in Hallenstadion-Dimension.
Das ist momentan ja alles abgesagt
oder verschoben
oder wird kleiner durchgeführt.
Wir haben schon immer Arbeit.
Wir müssen einfach schauen,
dass wir nicht
in ein Liquiditätsproblem rennen.
Das ist es, wenn man nicht weiss,
zu welchem Zeitpunkt man
die Rechnung stellen kann.
Momentan muss man schauen,
wie man damit umgeht.
Das kann man noch nicht genau sagen.
Es ist etwas eine Scheisszeit.
- Eine Scheisszeit?
Für uns wäre es der Horror,
wenn es so weitergeht.
Aber ja ... also ...
Was wir da noch nicht wissen:
Es wird so weitergehen.
Corina muss
ihre Yogaschule schliessen
und wird online Kurse anbieten
und ihr Freund
verliert alle Aufträge.
Das Virus hat schnell
die Wirtschaft angesteckt,
im Kleinen wie im Grossen.
Viele fürchten bereits
die grosse Rezession.
Corona wird zum Stresstest
für die ganze Gesellschaft.
11. März.
Ich besuche meine Nichte Leonie.
Sie studiert Medizin
an der Universität Zürich.
Ihre Fakultät wurde geschlossen.
* Türsummer *
Hallo. Ich begrüsse dich so.
- Hallo.
Du kannst die Jacke hierhin legen.
- Ich lege sie hierhin.
Jetzt bist du also
gezwungenermassen zu Hause.- Ja.
Wie ist die Situation an der Uni?
Ich muss die Vorlesungen
nachschauen, die ich verpasse,
weil ich nicht hingehen kann.
Klappt es mit den Podcasts?
- Nein, da ist noch gar nichts.
Ich finde es mühsam, denn ich
gehe immer gerne in die Vorlesungen.
Dort werden Dinge erklärt.
Und ich höre auch gern
einfach etwas zu.
Und man sieht seine Kollegen.
Und ... ja.
Und die Stimmung
unter den Studierenden?
Wir können nicht viel machen,
es ist jetzt halt einfach so.
Das mit den Vorlesungen ist mühsam.
Dass die Podcasts nicht kommen,
ist auch mühsam.
Es ist auch blöd, dass wir am
Nachmittag keine Kurse mehr haben.
Zuerst wollten sie die Kurse machen,
ohne Patientenkontakt,
und jetzt ist einfach
gar nichts mehr.
Ihr seid alles
angehende Ärztinnen und Ärzte.
Werdet ihr schon instruiert,
weil ihr evtl. zum Einsatz kommt?
Das weiss ich nicht,
weil ich erst im dritten Jahr bin.
Ich weiss nicht, ob sie Leute
aus dem sechsten Jahr einsetzen.
Das kann sein
und wäre auch nicht blöd.
Leonie lässt sich schon bald als
Freiwillige auf eine Liste setzen,
um das Spitalpersonal
zu unterstützen.
Was wir da noch nicht wissen:
Das Virus
wird noch vor Abschluss dieses Filmes
auch in ihrer Familie Einzug halten.
Ich besuche
das Universitätsspital Zürich.
Dort wird jetzt alles umgerüstet
für einen starken Anstieg
der Corona-Fälle.
Leere Hörsäle auch hier.
Kommen Sie mit?
- Ja, klar doch.
Was ist das? Ein Hörsaal?
Das wären Medizinstudenten
im vierten Jahr, es wäre voll,
300 Studierende,
aber jetzt ist es leer.
Sie sind alle zu Hause
und wir übertragen die Fortbildungen
über Streaming
zu den Studierenden nach Hause.
Gut. Das ist der Hörsaal.
Leonie wäre jetzt wohl hier.
Super.
- Sie kennt mich auch.
Es ist natürlich traurig für uns,
die Hörsäle so zeigen zu müssen,
denn sonst herrscht hier viel Leben.
Viele Medizinstudierende
wollen etwas tun
und haben sich für Einsätze gemeldet.
Hier brauchen Sie einen Badge.
Das haben wir gestern noch ...
Paola Massarotto führt mich
zu improvisierten Schulungsräumen.
Ist das sonst stillgelegt?
- Genau.
Wir sind auf der ehemaligen
Intensivstation für Brandverletzte.
Ah, das ist sonst leer?
- Genau.
Das haben wir gestern so aufgebaut,
dass wir einen Postenlauf
mit den Studierenden machen können,
damit sie ihre Skills trainieren
können, wirklich hands-on.
Gut, ich begrüsse euch herzlich.
Wir haben alle Posten vorbereitet.
In jeder Koje ist ein Posten.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt euch schon
in Gruppen eingeteilt.
In diesen Fünfergruppen
geht ihr jetzt von Posten zu Posten.
Medizinstudentinnen und -studenten
im letzten Ausbildungsjahr
werden hier kurzfristig geschult,
um bei Bedarf die Pflegefachleute
in der Klinik zu unterstützen.
Ich möchte kurz fragen:
Warum seid ihr hier?
Was ist die Motivation,
sich hier zu melden?
Einerseits das Wissen,
dass etwas kommt.
Das ist sicher.
Andererseits ...
- Was heisst "etwas"?
Corona ist eine erhöhte Belastung
für das Personal.
Ich habe im Unterassistenzjahr
gesehen, dass, wenn mehr kommt,
die Leute auch
extrem viel machen müssen.
Dort kann man entlasten.
Andererseits ist es auch
extrem gut zum Lernen.
Es ist gleich ein Real-life-Einsatz.
* Piepen *
Jetzt sehen wir: Es geht weiter.
Jetzt haben wir einen roten Alarm.
Hier müssen wir natürlich reagieren.
Das hat hohe Priorität.
Dann:
Das akustische Signal irritiert.
Wir kommen an die Maschine
und quittieren als Erstes den Alarm.
Das machen wir hiermit.
Darf ich etwas fragen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Was hat dieser Patient?
- Eine schwere Lungenentzündung.
Das könnte sein,
wenn er das Coronavirus hat?
Z.B., genau.
Deshalb schauen wir jetzt zusammen
die Beatmungseinheit an.
Genau, der Patient
hat eine schwere Lungenentzündung
und wird
mit dem Beatmungsgerät beatmet.
Eins, zwei, drei.
- So.
Pflegearbeiten, die sonst kaum
Ärztinnen und Ärzte übernehmen.
Ein wenig zurück.
Ich nehme sie auf meinen Arm
und ziehe sie nach hinten.
Die Idee für diesen
berufsübergreifenden Kurs
kommt von der Ärztin
Stephanie Klinzing.
Sie kennt das Konzept aus Dänemark.
Wir haben am Freitag
den Antrag gestellt,
dass wir dieses Projekt
aufgleisen wollen.
Übers Wochenende habe ich
das Konzeptionelle gemacht.
Am Montag haben wir uns getroffen
und am Mittwoch haben wir
mit der Schulung begonnen.
Ist das der Vorteil
einer solchen Krisensituation?
Ja, genau. Die
Entscheidungsfindungen waren kurz.
Was toll ist
und was es auszeichnet -
und das wird nicht nur
hier am Unispital so sein -,
ist, wie die Leute bereit sind,
sich einzubringen,
wie die Leute mit einem wahnsinnigen
Enthusiasmus dabei sind.
Die Studierenden haben sich bereits
eigenverantwortlich organisiert.
Die Flexibilität,
die sie an den Tag legen,
von allen Seiten.
Das ist einfach unglaublich.
Es ist ein positiver Höhepunkt
in dieser Zeit - unglaublich.
Diese Studierenden
müssten sich eigentlich
auf das Staatsexamen vorbereiten.
Ihr Engagement berührt mich.
Aber ich realisiere
in diesen Minuten auch,
dass der Ernstfall
tatsächlich wahrscheinlich ist.
Wir müssen damit rechnen,
dass die Fallzahlen in nächster Zeit
in der Schweiz massiv steigen.
Nach zwei weiteren Todesfällen
im Tessin ist die Zahl der Toten
in der Schweiz
auf insgesamt sechs gestiegen.
(Daniel Koch)
Jetzt muss man alles daran setzen,
dass wir nicht
zu viele Hospitalisationen
und v.a. nicht zu viele Menschen
auf den Intensivstationen haben.
Das Virus ist auch
in meinem Privatleben omnipräsent.
"Respekt vor dem Virus
scheint angebracht,
aber nicht Panik oder Hektik."
"Das Virus wird sich weiter ver-
breiten, bis ein Impfstoff da ist."
Ich glaube schon,
dass viele Menschen jetzt ...
... mehr Angst haben als sonst.
Meinst du nicht?
Ja, sicher.
Machst du dir Sorgen?
Ich?
- Ja. Machst du dir Sorgen?
Ja ... Es schwankt ein wenig.
Manchmal ja.
Und manchmal finde ich wieder:
"Nein, komm, es ist ja ..."
"Es ist ja nicht so schlimm."
Nein.
Ich finde, dass ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Dass es so gross wird,
so unkontrollierbar,
das finde ich etwas unheimlich.
Mhm.
"Was tut man, wenn jemand
im eigenen Haushalt Panik hat?"
Ja, das ist interessant.
Was tut man?
"Lass sie alle Schreckensszenarien
zu Ende denken."
"Tu das, weil bei Panik
das Denken steckenbleibt."
"Beharrt das Gegenüber
auf dem schwärzesten Szenario,
lass es Alternativen denken."
"Als Angehöriger hilft:
umarmen und festhalten."
"Bei Kindern nennt man das
Bärenumarmung."
"Angst richtet sich immer
auf die Zukunft."
"Zurück auf den Boden kommt man durch
basismässige körperliche Dinge."
Es ist schon spannend.
- Das machen wir alles.
Soll ich das mit dem Notvorrat
jetzt machen?
Soll ich mal schauen?
- Willst du wirklich bestellen?
Was?
- Willst du echt was bestellen?
Ja, jetzt schaue ich mal.
Gewisse Produkte
gibt es wirklich nicht mehr.
Und zwar:
Fertigrösti, Erbsen,
Borlotti-Bohnen.
Wir könnten mal
6 kg Kartoffeln bestellen.
Dann lagern wir die ein
und machen selbst Rösti.
Soll ich es bestellen?
- Das macht es noch schlimmer.
Wenn die Leute sehen,
dass es gewisse Dinge nicht gibt,
kriegen sie noch mehr Panik.
- Kann sein.
Wir haben keinen Notvorrat
für schwere Zeiten.
Dass Menschen jetzt hamstern,
ist uns fremd.
(Kinderstimme)
Sie hamstern in den Läden.
Sie kaufen Toilettenpapier,
damit sie nicht verhungern.
Nein, sorry,
aber jetzt spinnen die Leute!
Jetzt spinnen die Leute.
Das Problem ist ja nicht, dass wir
zu wenig Nahrungsmittel haben,
sondern dass jetzt alle spinnen
und Sachen kaufen,
die sie in zwei Monaten
wegwerfen werden.
Manche Leute
haben schon viel früher vorgesorgt.
Herr Panissidi?
- Grüezi.
Grüezi, Pfalzgraf
vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Wir begrüssen uns so.
- Okay.
Corona.
- Schön, dass wir kommen dürfen.
Räumen Sie auf?
Das nicht, aber ich suche etwas,
das ich brauche.
Es wirkt nicht so,
als ob es schwierig wäre.
Ist das typisch für Sie?
Das ist meine Unterschrift.
So denke ich und so lebe ich.
Was heisst das?
Das ist meine Art. Benno ist so.
Der tickt so.
Allzeit bereit, kann ich nur sagen.
- Allzeit bereit.
Aber Herr Panissidi, wir sind
eigentlich wegen Ihrer Vorräte hier.
Genau.
- Zeigen Sie uns diese?
Die sind natürlich woanders.
- Wo denn?
Kommen Sie mit, ich zeige es Ihnen.
- Sehr gerne.
Sagen Sie mal, warum haben Sie
so viele Lebensmittel?
Warum? Das hat damit angefangen,
weil meine Mutter
den Zweiten Weltkrieg erlebt hat.
Sie hatte immer Notvorräte zu Hause.
Und ich habe das weitergeführt.
Vor etwa zehn Jahren, etwas mehr,
habe ich angefangen,
hier einen Notvorrat anzulegen.
Und über die Jahre
ist er angewachsen.
Hier sind Haushaltprodukte.
Hier haben wir Reis und Teigwaren.
Ich habe übrigens auch ...
Das hier sind 250 Eier.
Auch Milch habe ich in Pulverform.
Das ist eine kleine Packung.
Das kann man mit Wasser anrühren
und erhält dann Rührei.
Das ist perfekt.
Haben Sie es schon ausprobiert?
- Ja, darum sind die Klammern dran.
Was sagt Ihre Frau?
Findet sie es gut?
Sie steht voll dahinter.
Am Anfang fand sie:
"Übertreibst du es nicht?"
Ich sagte ihr dann:
"Schatz, man weiss nie."
Aber ist es vielleicht etwas zu viel?
Nein, denn das wird ständig rotiert.
Und Foodwaste gibt es auch nicht.
Als das mit den leeren Regalen
anfing, sagte ich zu meiner Frau:
"Wir bleiben zu Hause
und gehen nicht raus."
"Wir brauchen keine Dosen, nichts.
Kein Wasser, keine Spaghetti."
"Wir haben alles. Wir können
die Tür abschliessen und fertig."
Ehrlich gesagt schienen mir
sog. Prepper immer etwas seltsam.
Aber er hamstert nicht planlos.
Das beeindruckt mich.
Das ist das sog. Hauskraftwerk.
Das regelt den ganzen Strom,
der vom Dach kommt.
Sie sind also auch
Energieselbstversorger?- Genau.
Dann läuft alles -
Kühlschrank, Tiefkühltruhe ...
Sie sind autark, Sie haben
einen Notvorrat an Lebensmitteln -
ist die jetzige Situation
eine Bestätigung für Sie?
"Ich habe es doch immer gesagt!"
Ich verspürte in mir
eine innerliche Genugtuung.
Ich sagte mir: "Du bist doch nicht
das grösste A..., das rumläuft."
Lange Zeit war nichts, und plötzlich
ging es mit dem Coronavirus los.
Aus dem Nichts. Und wie es
weitergeht, wissen wir nicht.
Nein, das wissen wir nicht.
Manche Menschen geraten in Panik
und verhalten sich irrational.
Die Migros hat
eine Informationsoffensive lanciert,
um die Leute zu beruhigen.
Es ist ganz wichtig, zu sagen,
dass wir meilenweit von einer
schweren Mangellage entfernt sind.
Die Lager sind gut gefüllt,
für Nachschub ist gesorgt.
Man muss sich keine Sorgen machen.
Es kann passieren, dass gewisse
Artikel kurzfristig vergriffen sind,
aber wir arbeiten daran,
die Logistik und was damit
zusammenhängt, am Laufen zu halten.
In Zeiten von Corona
ist der Austausch an der Kasse
bereits etwas unangenehm.
Bald wird Bargeld
aus dem Alltag verschwinden.
Jetzt geht es.
Die Angestellten
sind der Gefahr direkt ausgesetzt,
werden aber instruiert.
Wird das dauernd desinfiziert?
- Ja, das machen wir.
Ja, wir desinfizieren immer.
Schon wenige Tage später
gehören bei den Grossverteilern
Hygienemasken und Plexiglasscheiben
zur Normalität.
Für jeden Lebensmittelbetrieb
wäre ein Corona-Fall katastrophal.
Der Geschäftsführer der Confiserie
Bachmann in Luzern hat sich gewappnet
und eine Wärmebildkamera angeschafft.
Fiebermessen ab sofort obligatorisch.
(Computerstimme) Bitte bleiben Sie
auf der Markierung stehen.
Legen Sie, wenn vorhanden,
Ihre Brille und Kopfbedeckung ab.
Der Zutritt wird gewährt.
Bitte gehen Sie weiter.
Bitte bleiben Sie
auf der Markierung stehen.
Der Zutritt wird gewährt.
Bitte gehen Sie weiter.
Hier ist eine Haube,
um die Haare abzudecken.
Müssen alle Haare drunter?
- Ja.
Perfekt, sehr gut.
- Schön, dass es rosa ist!
Wie sieht es aus? Tipptopp, gut.
Ich kann Ihnen zeigen, was passiert,
wenn jemand Übertemperatur hat.
Ich habe hier heisses Wasser und
gehe noch mal durch die Schleuse.
Voilà.
Bitte bleiben Sie
auf der Markierung stehen.
Legen Sie, wenn vorhanden,
Ihre Brille und Kopfbedeckung ab.
Die gemessene Temperatur
ist zu hoch.
Der Zutritt zu weiteren Räumlich-
keiten ist Ihnen strikte untersagt.
Danke für Ihr Verständnis.
D.h., Sie würden
sofort avisiert werden?
Ich würde eine E-Mail, SMS
oder einen Anruf bekommen.
Wir würden diese Person abfangen,
Fieber messen und sie befragen
und dann Massnahmen ergreifen.
Das ist unsere Hygieneschleuse.
Hier kommt etwas Seife.
Schön.
- Man geht hindurch.
Und dann können wir hier
die Hände waschen.
Das machen Sie aber
nicht erst seit Corona.
Nein, die Hygieneschleuse
hatten wir bereits.
Als Lebensmittelbetrieb
ist Hygiene sehr wichtig.
Dort gibt es Desinfektionsmittel.
- Zusätzlich?- Genau.
Und dann gehen wir hoch
in die Produktion.
Jetzt habe ich aber saubere Hände.
Diese Wärmebildkamera unten,
warum haben Sie diese anschafft?
Wir haben uns Gedanken gemacht,
wie wir dem entgegenwirken könnten.
Das eine war
der Schutz der Mitarbeiter -
dass wir jene mit Grippesymptomen
abfangen können.
Und das andere war
die Aufrechterhaltung des Betriebs.
War es einfach,
diese jetzt schnell zu montieren?
Es war sehr schwierig,
weil die Lieferfrist der Kamera
sehr lang ist.
Wir haben das letzte in Europa
verfügbare Modell bekommen.
Aber wir brauchten eine,
die sehr genau misst,
denn es werden pro Tag
über 700 Messungen vorgenommen.
Das sind ja nicht nur Mitarbeitende,
das sind auch Handwerker,
Besucher - sobald wir wieder
Besucher zulassen dürfen.
Und auch die Lieferanten
müssen dort durch.
In Kauf und Installation
der Wärmebildanlage
hat Bachmann
rund 20'000 Fr. investiert.
Andere KMU haben inzwischen
Kurzarbeit anmelden müssen.
Das Coronavirus trifft
mit voller Wucht die Wirtschaft.
Das Virus
macht auch zunehmend dem Tourismus
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
In der Schweiz keine Touristen.
Die WHO spricht jetzt
von einer Pandemie
und mir scheint, kaum jemand
kann richtig einschätzen,
was das bedeutet.
Fakten und Spekulationen ohne Pause.
Die Zahl der Infektionen
steigt rasant.
Was heisst das für uns?
Ich gehe nochmals
ans Universitätsspital Zürich.
Aber heute
überlege ich mir zum ersten Mal,
ob ich wirklich noch
den Bus nehmen soll.
Im USZ liegen
die ersten Corona-Patienten
und es werden wohl
noch viele mehr werden.
In den Spitälern sind
die Intensivstationen gefordert.
Noch dürfen wir hier filmen.
Hier die Einschleusung,
dort die Ausschleusung,
dazwischen das Zimmer.
In diesem Teil zieht man sich um.
Hier ist
das ganze Material vorhanden.
Wir haben Masken, Mäntel.
Am Schluss ist man so angezogen.
Wir ziehen eine Schutzbrille an.
Man muss sich eintragen,
wenn man reingeht.
So wissen wir,
wer wie lange drin war.
Dann muss man sich austragen.
Hier ist also jemand
mit Coronavirus drin?- Genau.
Diese Patientin ist
seit drei oder vier Tagen hier.
Wir erwarten, dass sie noch
eine oder zwei Wochen hierbleibt.
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
die Botschaft des Abstandhaltens,
des Desinfizierens ist angekommen?
Es ist bei vielen
noch nicht angekommen.
Wir müssen auch aufpassen,
dass wir es einhalten.
Aber ich predige es immer wieder
und versuche, das Team
darauf aufmerksam zu machen,
dass es ein Selbstschutz ist.
Und dass viele junge Leute -
bei uns arbeiten viele Junge -
asymptomatische Träger sein,
es weitergeben und
die Familie anstecken können.
Wahrscheinlich wird es einem erst
bewusst, wenn die Zahlen ansteigen
und Familienmitglieder
betroffen sind.
Aber dann ist es zu spät.
Womit rechnen Sie jetzt?
Wir hatten ja gehofft,
die Ansteckungskurve
flach halten zu können.
Im Moment sieht es aus,
als würde sie eher steil werden.
Wir richten uns jetzt darauf ein,
dass wir viele Patienten
haben werden
in ein, zwei oder drei Wochen.
Nebenan wird
ein stillgelegter Intensivtrakt
wieder in Betrieb genommen.
Das ist
die vorbereitete Intensivstation,
wenn es mehr Patienten gibt
und wir Platz brauchen.
Wie viele dieser neuen Betten
gibt es?
Wir werden 16 Plätze einrichten.
Momentan ist eine Seite frei,
es sind jetzt also acht Betten.
Sind Sie zum ersten Mal mit
einer solchen Situation konfrontiert?
Ja, es ist wohl für viele
das erste Mal.
Was heisst das für Sie persönlich?
Es ist eine interessante
und gleichzeitig etwas ...
... beängstigende Situation.
Wir wissen nicht genau,
was auf uns zukommt
und womit wir rechnen dürfen.
Wir sind tagsüber bei den Patienten,
aber wir haben auch
unser eigenes soziales Umfeld.
Wir haben Eltern, Grosseltern.
Wie geht es ihnen?
Das sind
sehr belastende Situationen.
Es ist uns auch ein Anliegen,
dass wir nach jeder Schicht
wenigstens ein Debriefing machen,
damit wir wissen,
wie es uns als Team geht.
Die Taskforce des USZ
kommt auch an diesem Tag zusammen.
Sie muss ständig reagieren, die Lage
ändert sich praktisch stündlich.
Wir sollten heute um 18 Uhr
einen Besuchsstopp machen.
Wenn wir das durchziehen,
haben wir genug Zeit
zur Vorbereitung für 18 Uhr.
Die Stimmung
ist unglaublich angespannt.
Ein Besucherstopp: beschlossen und
umgesetzt innerhalb weniger Stunden.
Eine drastische Massnahme.
Es gibt viele Leute,
die gar nicht mithalten können
mit unseren Überlegungen für die
wirklich schwierige Pandemiephase,
wenn wir von Patienten
überrannt werden.
Im Moment
ist es noch übersichtlich.
Aber ich habe jetzt
auf der Intensivstation angefangen,
45 Min. mit den einzelnen Gruppen
zusammenzusitzen
und ihnen zu erklären:
"Diese Überlegungen sind
für in zwei bis vier Wochen,
aber wir müssen vorbereitet sein."
Wird unser Gesundheitssystem
standhalten?
Werde ich krank?
Was ist mit meiner Familie?
Ich bin permanent am Handy.
Die Informationsflut ist zermürbend.
Auch in der Schweiz
verbreitet sich Corona schnell.
Heute kam
ein weiterer Todesfall hinzu.
Die Angst wird grösser.
Wie ist mit diesem Ausnahmezustand
auf längere Zeit umzugehen?
Vielleicht hat der Therapeut
Antworten auf die nagenden Fragen,
die viele beschäftigen.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit,
der Panik zu entkommen?
Aus dieser Spirale rauszukommen?
Wenn es keine rationale Angst ist,
die gesund ist,
dann geht es v.a. darum, erst mal
zu schauen, was die Ursache ist.
Bin ich vielleicht
zu wenig informiert?
Weiss ich nicht genau,
was das Coronavirus ist
oder wie ich mich davor schütze.
Dabei hilft Information.
Aber Angst kann auch entstehen, wenn
ich fast schon überinformiert bin.
Wenn ich links und rechts versuche,
möglichst viel Information
zu finden.
Vielleicht auch
bei weniger seriösen Quellen.
Also auf allen Kanälen.
Ich muss nicht stündlich wissen,
was gerade abläuft.
wie viele neue Infizierte es gibt.
Aber ich kann mich einmal am Tag
auf dem Laufenden halten,
mal schauen, was die Medien sagen.
Aber eben, vielleicht Push-
Benachrichtigungen deinstallieren
oder blockieren,
sodass ich nicht
die ganze Zeit Meldungen,
die vielleicht angstauslösend sind,
bekomme.
Aber natürlich gibt es auch
die Erwartungsangst:
Was ist, wenn es so weit kommt?
Das ist auch einer der Gründe,
warum ich mich
in eine Angst reinsteigern kann.
Denn dieses "Was wäre wenn" kann
unendlich weitergesponnen werden.
Kann man das stoppen?
Dieser Gedanke, der nicht
zu Ende gedacht wird, macht Angst.
Wenn ich ihn konkret werden lasse
und mir Möglichkeiten überlege,
wie ich damit umgehen kann,
dann habe ich mehr Kontrolle
über die Situation.
Und das beruhigt.
13. März.
Eigentlich wollte ich ja
einen Film über Overtourism machen.
Die Rigibahn z.B. war immer übervoll
mit asiatischen Touristen.
Jetzt sind die Reisegruppen
verschwunden.
Nichts ist mehr wie vor Corona.
Nirgends.
Die Umwälzungen sind kaum zu fassen.
Ich habe mir News-Diät verordnet,
muss meine Gedanken sortieren,
durchatmen.
Da dachte ich noch,
dass dies ein schönes Schlussbild
für den Film sein könnte.
Aber nein, noch einmal
überschlagen sich die Ereignisse.
Europa kämpft
gegen das Coronavirus.
An Schulen
wird nicht mehr unterrichtet.
Der Bundesrat hat entschieden,
dass alle privaten und öffentlichen
Veranstaltungen verboten sind.
Für die Wirtschaft stehen
10 Mrd. Fr. Soforthilfe bereit.
Der Bundesrat
verschärft die Massnahmen.
Die Pandemie ist endgültig angekommen
in der Schweiz.
Wie weiter?
An Schulen wird bis am 4. April
nicht mehr unterrichtet.
Bis Ende April sind Veranstaltungen
mit über 100 Personen verboten.
Für die Wirtschaft stehen 10 Mrd.
Fr. als Soforthilfe zur Verfügung.
Auch bei SRF
herrscht Ausnahmezustand.
Meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
im Newsroom
arbeiten unter zusätzlichem Druck
für Sondersendungen.
Guten Morgen.
- Das Bundeshaus fehlt noch.
Ich bin wieder dabei.
- Gut.
Gut, dann fangen wir mit Inland an.
Für die "Tagesschau" gesetzt
ist das Einrücken der Truppen.
Diese Truppen gehen nicht in den WK,
sondern sie rücken
auf unbestimmte Zeit ein.
Nufi, kannst du
dein Programm durchgeben?
(Am Handy) Ja.
Wir haben die Geschichte
mit der Armee,
die heute in Moudon einrückt.
Was wir noch gesehen haben,
vielleicht für morgen:
Ein Spital im Kanton Baselland
prüft ernsthaft Kurzarbeit.
Diverse Länder
haben die Grenzen dichtgemacht.
Als Beispiel die Schwellenländer,
denn die trifft es brutal hart.
Es gibt so viele Fragen
rund um das Virus,
gesundheitliche, wirtschaftliche.
Die Bewegungsfreiheit der Menschen,
es wird immer dramatischer.
Insofern gibt es für eine
Newssendung gar nichts anderes.
Homeoffice ist nun Pflicht.
Nur wer unbedingt muss,
kommt ins Büro.
Alle Schulen sind zu.
Abertausende von Familien sind ge-
zwungen, ihren Alltag neu zu ordnen,
auch die Familie
meiner Kollegin Mona Vetsch.
Es ist fast etwas unheimlich.
- Ja, das ist es.
Deshalb wollte ich fragen,
wie es dir geht.
Tag 1 ohne Schule.
Es ist Tag 1 ohne Schule.
Am Freitag erfuhren wir,
dass wir die drei Jungs
für mind. fünf Wochen
im Haus haben werden.
Und was ist passiert?
Uns ging es wohl gleich
wie vielen anderen.
Wir sind in wilden Aktionismus
ausgebrochen.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Wir haben Pläne gemacht.
Ich habe einen Wochenplan erstellt,
was an welchem Tag passiert.
Am Morgen Sport, am Vormittag
Arbeitsblätter ausfüllen.
Was wir auch ins Leben gerufen
haben, ist ein Corona-Tagebuch.
So sieht das aus.
- Das ist aber cool.
Und helfen da alle mit?
Alle helfen mit.
Antonin ist acht Jahre alt
und er hat geschrieben:
"Ich habe schulfrei
und ich finde, es ist kool". Mit K.
"Aber meine Eltern
finden es eher nicht so kool."
Wo sind denn deine Jungs jetzt?
Irgendwo beschäftigt?
Denn zu Hause sein
ist ja eigentlich nicht arbeiten.
Aha!
Hier.
Genau, für sie natürlich nicht.
Sie diskutieren dort draussen,
wie wir
die nächsten Tage gestalten werden.
Und wie geht es dir selbst?
Ich ... Ich weiss nicht.
Eigentlich mag ich ja
so besondere Situationen,
in denen man spontan sein muss.
Aber wenn ich mal dazu komme,
darüber nachzudenken,
merke ich schon, dass ich abends
länger zum Einschlafen brauche.
Mir geht so viel durch den Kopf.
Noch am gleichen Tag
folgt der nächste Paukenschlag.
Der Bundesrat hat heute entschieden,
die Situation zur
ausserordentlichen Lage zu erklären.
Bleiben Sie zu Hause. Vermeiden Sie
Kontakt mit anderen Personen.
Ich fahre nicht mehr Tram.
Und nur zum Drehen
sind wir gemeinsam unterwegs.
Wir fahren nochmals
ins Universitätsspital.
Nur eine Woche ist seit
unserem ersten Besuch vergangen,
aber die Lage
hat sich völlig verändert.
Zufällig treffe ich vor dem Eingang
auf Intensivpflegefachfrau
Paola Massarotto. Sie wirkt bedrückt.
Die Welle von COVID-Fällen
sei jetzt da.
Im Moment
fahren wir möglichst viel hoch.
Ich wünsche euch viel Energie.
Und bleib gesund.
Das werden wir versuchen.
- Ciao.
* Seufzen *
Was für ein Alptraum!
Für einen Moment kann ich der Angst
nichts mehr entgegensetzen.
* Leises Schluchzen *
Hoffentlich hält das Spitalpersonal
dieser Belastung stand.
Ich warte auf Peter Steiger.
Hallo.
Wunderbar, danke schön.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Wie geht's?
Danke, es läuft wie verrückt.
Wir sehen jetzt,
dass es stark anzieht.
D.h., seit gestern steigen
die Patientenzahlen, wie berechnet,
exponentiell an.
Die Patienten, die hier sind, sind
aber alles vorbelastete Personen?
Nicht nur.
Wir hatten auch Patienten, die
sehr wenig Vorerkrankungen hatten,
z.B. Bluthochdruck,
aber sonst nichts.
Wir konnten bereits jemanden
aus der Intensivstation entlassen.
Gestorben
ist zum Glück noch niemand.
Fast alle Patienten
haben Nierenversagen.
Bei den meisten
ist die Leber auch betroffen.
Sie haben ...
... eine Herzentzündung.
Und sie wachen sehr langsam auf,
wenn man die Schlafmittel stoppt.
Was ist Ihre grösste Sorge?
Die grösste Sorge ist,
dass das Personal krank wird,
denn das wird
der grosse Engpass werden.
Wenn man nur Geräte
und kein Personal hat,
wird der Patient nicht behandelt.
Was wäre Ihr Appell
an die Bevölkerung?
Ich bitte jeden,
der chronische Erkrankungen hat,
und jeden,
der im Alters- oder Pflegeheim ist
und zur Risikogruppe gehört, eine
Patientenverfügung zu erstellen,
damit für uns ganz klar ist,
ob eine Intensivtherapie
in dieser schwierigen Situation
gewünscht ist oder nicht.
Sollen wir alles unternehmen
oder nicht?
Wie weit sollen wir gehen?
Es berührt mich, wie die Bevölkerung
ihre Wertschätzung
für das Gesundheitspersonal kundtut.
Gleichzeitig denke ich,
noch besser als Klatschen wäre
mehr Lohn für diese wichtige Arbeit.
Genau drei Wochen sind seit Beginn
der Dreharbeiten vergangen
und die Welt
ist eine vollkommen andere.
Ich hoffe,
dass wir die Entschleunigung,
die Solidarität
und die Menschlichkeit
hinüberretten
in die Zeit nach Corona.
Die Krise wird sich in unser
kollektives Gedächtnis einprägen.
Und alle müssen einen Weg finden,
sich dem neuen Alltag anzupassen.
Homeoffice - wie fühlt es sich an?
Jetzt stehen wir alle
in der Verantwortung.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
M. Gassner, A. Duttweiler - 2020